If you’ve ever taken a vacation to one of
the many islands of Greece, then you’ll
know why the likes of Crete, Lesbos, and Corfu
are famous for their beautiful beaches.
But there is one beach in particular, tucked
away in a corner of an unknown island that
you might think twice about visiting.
Why?
Well, the same reasons that this place happens
to be a site of great interest for the SCP
Foundation also tend to drive tourists away.
Today, we’re talking about SCP-2217, the
strange anomalous happenings that have taken
place there, and how it links to none other
than one of the Foundation’s most infamous
Groups of Interest.
At first glance, SCP-2217 is an ordinary,
uninteresting beach, just another pretty,
picturesque view on a Greek island.
It looks like the kind of place that would
be perfect for a romantic walk at sunset.
But we wouldn’t recommend it.
Although you wouldn’t know just from looking
at it, the sand that this beach is composed
of has some pretty peculiar properties.
It contains the ordinary, non-anomalous things
you’d find in sand anywhere else in the
world, normal levels of silicates and calcium
compounds.
But the beach also possesses a high concentration
of cationic metallic particles.
These tiny, almost microscopic metal fragments
somehow hold an electrical charge despite
being grounded.
So, it’s a beach with partially metal sand,
nothing too unusual there, right?
Wrong.
The metallic particles within the sand seem
to have a profound effect on the natural environment
around SCP-2217.
For one, the metal content of the beach influences
the weather, increasing the number of lighting
strikes that hit the shore, the metals drawing
the static electricity in the atmosphere.
This, along with other weather conditions
and natural processes that take place at SCP-2217,
also have a far more obvious anomalous effect.
Lightning, rain, even fish washed up and decaying
on the shoreline have all caused various artificial
structures and devices to rise from the beach,
which have all been designated by the Foundation
as SCP-2217-1
Among the creations found on the beach in
the wake of lightning strikes are a number
of different forms of machinery.
These have included simple clocks and other
timepieces, to complicated automatons.
These machines have no notable anomalous properties
as far as the SCP Foundation have found, apart
from the way they came to be; and they are
otherwise fully functional.
Also discovered at SCP-2217 was jewellery,
seeming to be made of discarded waste that
washed up on the beach in the tide.
Resembling bears and other recurring motifs
of a certain religion, these articles of jewellery
have been made using everything from old lightbulbs,
to hulls of ships and even fish and animal
bones.
Most notably, however, was the appearance
of a city.
Or rather, a model of a city that was created
at the beach and was then referred to as SCP-2217-A1.
There is a cliff located on SCP-2217, and
if one is to swim through an underwater entrance,
they will find themselves inside a grotto.
There, somehow carved by tidal erosion of
the rock, is a recreation of an Ancient Greek
city, although the geographical features of
the model seem to resemble an area near Lake
Baikal in Southern Siberia.
The city bears more of the same religious
iconography to the jewelry that can often
be found on the beach, but which religion?
The same one that considers SCP-2217 to be
a site of holy importance: The Church of the
Broken God.
Now, some important context to make note of.
For any who are unaware, The Church of The
Broken God is a religious organization that
the SCP Foundation has had a number of encounters
with over the years.
Members of the Church share in the belief
that biological, flesh based life is inherently
wrong, an abomination, even evil.
This religion worships mechanization; the
process of making something, or someone, more
mechanical in nature.
According to the beliefs of the Church, there
were two gods: Yaldabaoth and Mekhane, who
created humanity together.
Yaldabaoth was the god of flesh and animal
instinct, granting humans bodies.
Meanwhile, the god of machine and intellect,
Mekhane, blessed man with the power of free
thought.
As humankind developed its civilizations by
building machines, Yaldabaoth became enraged
that they were ignoring the instincts she
had bestowed upon them.
She endeavored to destroy the creations of
man, in an attempt to revert them to the animals
she had intended them to be.
As the Church’s legend goes, Mekhane acted
as humanity’s savior, and tried desperately
to stop Yaldabaoth.
The god of machines shattered himself, transforming
his body into a number of pieces to form a
cage for his fellow god.
Fragments of Mekhane rained down on planet
Earth.
Now, the Church of the Broken God believes
it is their duty to recover these missing
parts, and put their savior back together.
Within the religion of the Church of the Broken
God there exists a splinter faction that broke
away from the main Church.
This group, referred to as the Broken Church,
are the ones that regard SCP-2217 so highly,
considering it to be a holy site.
According to a piece of scripture from their
religion, the Broken Church believes the beach
to be Mekhane’s “workshop.”
The Book of Rites describes the legend of
a boy looking out at the ocean with his family,
and seeing fire rain down on the shore, sent
from God, or Mekhane to the Church.
Mekhane apparently proclaimed that the beach
was his workshop, where he “made many wonders.”
“The lightning is my hammer, the Earth my
anvil, the sand my ingot,” Mekhane explained
to the boy, so the legend goes, and invited
the child into his workshop.
The Broken God brought his hammer down on
the boy, but instead of killing him, marked
him as the first of the religion The Broken
Church now follows.
In 2014, the SCP Foundation recorded an earthquake
taking place at SCP-2217, with the grotto
containing the model Ancient Greek city at
the epicenter.
Sending a robotic probe into the grotto to
assess the damage, only to find a surprising
change that had occurred.
For the first time, there were a number of
humanoid figures seen within SCP-2217-A1,
and worse still, they were under attack.
Within the model city, what appeared to be
a number of individuals infected with SCP-610
were ransacking buildings, devouring and infecting
the other humanoid figures.
Also known as ‘The Flesh that Hates’,
SCP-610 is a contagious skin disease.
It is usually transmitted by direct skin to
skin contact, and anyone that is infected
with it suffers a horrific mutation that transforms
them into fleshy, inhuman monstrosities.
These infected creatures will attack and infect
anyone nearby that isn’t also carrying SCP-610.
Interestingly, the disease was first discovered
to be localized to a small area in Siberia,
not dissimilar to the area that the SCP-2217-A1
model resembled.
According to some sources, SCP-610 is “The
Flesh”, described by those following the
religion of Sarkicism, a cult that worships
flesh and disease.
Sarkicism is a sect that directly opposes
and antagonizes the machine-revering Church
of the Broken God.
Three years after the earthquake, members
of the Broken Church staged an attack on the
beach, hoping to reclaim SCP-2217 for their
religion.
At the time, The SCP Foundation had closed
off the area to the public, under the cover
story that SCP-2217 was private property.
They had been hoping to predict the lighting
strikes that caused the anomalous devices
to form on the beach.
Instead, the Foundation had to repel the Broken
Church’s attackers any way they could.
However, as the lightning began to strike
again, members of Foundation personnel that
found themselves caught in it seemed to change
sides, all stating that “God needs to be
reassembled”.
Only a year later in 2018, another group of
Broken Church zealots stormed the beach and
the Foundation outpost located there.
This time, the Church seemed to have gained
further reinforcements, specifically members
of other Groups of Interest.
In particular, some belonging to the Church
of Maxwellism and the Cogwork Orthodox Church,
both of which were also splinter groups of
the Church of the Broken God.
The Cogwork Orthodox Church arose during the
Industrial Revolution, believing that adding
mechanical parts to their own bodies offered
greater understanding of Mekhane, and brought
them closer to their god.
Maxwellism, in a similar vein, had another
interpretation of the Church’s core beliefs,
favoring smaller, more advanced cybernetic
implants.
The Church of Maxwellism sought to modify
their brains to become a collective consciousness
and commune with Mekhane.
Despite a lot of pre-existing animosity between
the three core splinter groups of the Church,
they were able to successfully capture SCP-2217.
The three factions sent a video message to
the Foundation, proclaiming the importance
of their mission.
“Oh, disassemblers who call themselves a
Foundation: what are you a Foundation for?
If you are a Foundation for life, then you
will let us keep this land.
For the flesh is coming, and only we can stop
it.
We need to bring our God back together immediately,
or else you will all perish…
And now, it is time.
If you are a Foundation for life, you will
not let this happen.
You will let us defeat the flesh.”
Several more messages were sent to the Foundation,
demanding the release of various SCPs with
connections to the Broken God.
You see, there could potentially be hundreds
of pieces needed to rebuild Mekhane so he
can lead the Church to glory and defeat Yaldabaoth.
A number of these pieces happen to be catalogued
SCPs that the Foundation is either aware of,
or has in containment.
These include SCP-882 or “His Broken Heart”
to the Church, SCP-271, “His Broken Gift”,
SCP-813, “His Broken Eyes”, SCP-1139,
“His Broken Tongue”, SCP-635, “His Broken
Mind”, and finally “His Broken Blood”,
which refers to SCP-217.
With the beach under the control of the Church
of the Broken God, any Foundation personnel
left alive on SCP-2217 defected and joined
the Church.
In order to retake the beach and re-establish
containment, the Foundation was forced to
do something that they only do in the most
dire of circumstances: Ask for help.
Together with the Horizon Initiative and Global
Occult Coalition, the SCP Foundation established
what it called The Triumvirate, a joint task
force.
In 2019, another earthquake was detected.
This time in Lake Baikal, Siberia, where SCP-610
was contained.
Not long after, infected individuals were
reported to be attacking Foundation forces
in the area, causing heavy casualties.
But then an unlikely event took place.
Members of the Church of the Broken God appeared,
their bodies augmented with machinery.
These zealots that had fought the Foundation
for control of SCP-2217, were now coming to
its aid to repel SCP-610.
According to them, God, or rather Mekhane,
had told them to come to assist The Foundation.
Using a large-scale electrical discharge,
instances of the SCP-610 contagion were eradicated,
but this discharge seemed to have originated
from the same island where SCP-2217 was found.
Following this incident, Robert Bumaro, the
leader of the Broken Church, sent a video
message to the leaders of the Triumvirate,
including the O5 Council, the Director of
the Global Occult Coalition, and the Horizon
Initiative’s Tribunal.
In his message, Bumaro stated:
“It's not too late, you know.
This is our world, as well.
We both want the Flesh to end.
And we can help you; we can help each other.
Come to the Anvil.
We will talk, and we can save this world.”
The Church of the Broken God, its splinter
groups uniting to take SCP-2217 for their
religion, were now extending an olive branch
to the Foundation and its allies, all in the
name of protecting the world.
Shortly after, the Foundation, Global Occult
Coalition and Horizon Initiative began working
collaboratively with the Church of the Broken
God, to prepare for an XK-Class Scenario.
Retaking control of the SCP-2217 beach for
now, the Foundation intends to revoke this
current arrangement after the dangerous scenario
has been averted.
But perhaps Mekhane’s workshop will prove
vital in reassembling the Broken God and saving
humanity, should Yaldabaoth ever return to
exact her terrible revenge.
Now go check out “SCP-001 - The Broken God
- Ouroboros Cycle” and “SCP-5094 - Miss
J's Whiz Kidz Schoolhouse” for more technological
SCPs!